I'm sitting in the control room of the
GSI Institute the control room of the
linear accelerator that was used to
create element 111 and five of the other
super-heavy elements the idea of this is
that you have a metal target usually led
or bismuth elements 82 or 83 and you
take a lighter element say copper and
bang the copper at huge velocity into
the lead or the bismuth depending the
element that you want to make the idea
is that you have to accelerate them very
fast so that the two positively charged
nuclei can come together but not so fast
that you have a lot of energy and they
immediately fall apart again okay this
is the periodic table of the elements
that was used for the cry ceiling of
element 111 which was called roentgenium
and you see you can remove this cube
here and secret Hofmann the head of the
group who discovered the elements and
our minister Annetta sherman together
inserted the cube into the periodic
table of the elements and it actually
started to glow
oh it was an amazing day we had a huge
ceremony 1000 people came here for the
cry singing afterwards there was cake
and champagne and it was really good
element 111 has a name which is really
difficult to pronounce roentgenium which
is named after roentgen the discovery of
x-rays I just find that it's a
combination of letters that people in
England find difficult to pronounce
however roentgen was I believe the first
Nobel Prize winner or one of the first
Nobel Prize winners and so it is really
quite fitting that he should have an
element's named after him the first
discovery was of three atoms of this
element and then the experiments were
repeated and another three were found so
it was still relatively quite a small
number but it's very important when
somebody does a series of these
experiments that you have to repeat them
to make sure that you've really seen
what you think you want you're really
excited you want to make a new element
and so it's quite easy to fool yourself
or sometimes people could be tempted to
cheat so you really have to repeat it
ideally you get a different lab in a
different place using a different route
and if two people get the same results
you'll pretty tall but in this case I
think the two runs were repeated here
and it was still a whole period of 10 or
12 years between the discovery of the
elements and it being finally named
because people want to be absolutely
sure that the data are correct
the machine that makes these ions is
enormous and it takes a whole team of
operators to control it and all this
stuff behind me is to control the power
the voltages and so on under different
parts of the accelerator that takes the
iron beam to this tiny chamber it's
really only about this size where the
actual experiment took place and once
the atom is made it then flies off to
detector that's two Romans away down a
long tube yeah of course we are waiting
now for the final confirmation to Christ
an element 112 which is going to be
copernicium but well we don't know yet
what we're going to do for the cry
ceiling we're having discussions what
we're going to do and I think it will be
a big surprise